en temps une audition de la commission
des affaires sociales sur les ehpad une
commission des affaires sociales doté
des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête et comme vous voyez sur ces
images en direct elle reçoit ce matin
les cadres dirigeants du groupe orpea
france ainsi que ceux de korian ils sont
en train de s'installer sans plus
attendre direction la salle de la
commission pour écouter cette audition
journalistique le fossoyeur le 26
janvier dernier
cet ouvrage points notamment
l'inadéquation de la forme actuelle des
contrôles opérés non pas sur les groupes
mais sur les établissements et la grande
difficulté des autorités à s'assurer du
bon emploi de l'argent public c'est
pourquoi notre commission a choisi de
s'intéresser à la question du contrôle
nous avons souhaité que cette audition
intervienne à quelque distance
d'apparition du livre une fois l'émotion
légitime un peu retombée et surtout afin
de disposer non pas seulement d'une
enquête journalistique fut-elle de
qualité mais aussi du rapport des
inspections depuis les événements se
sont succédés temps le gouvernement pour
annoncer la saisine d'injustice que le
groupe orpea pour présenter des excuses
ont fait de nouvelles annonces je
voudrais avant toute chose rappeler
quelques éléments cette commission
denquête n'est pas un tribunal nous
sommes ici pour comprendre et pour
formuler des préconisations de
politiques publiques en second lieu il
ne s'agit pas non plus de jeter
l'opprobre sur tout un secteur d'une
construction très bien les
problématiques l'état de dépendance
accrue des résidents la difficulté dans
un secteur de main d'oeuvre qui souffre
d'un déficit important d'attractivité à
recruter à former à fidéliser des
personnels et la question toujours non
résolu du financement nous avons aussi
la grande sensibilité du sujet confirmée
par le succès du livre qui touche un
public très large chacun se sentant
concernées pour ses proches ou
anticipant la question de sa propre
vulnérabilité
en votre nom à tous je voudrais redire
notre confiance dans l'engagement des
professionnels du secteur comme notre
volonté de soutenir les résidents et
leurs proches nous savons enfin quelle
peut être la ville n'a rien vu venir
habilité d'une entreprise au risque de
réputation c'est aussi pourquoi nous
avons été surpris qu'une entreprise
puisse elle même mettre en danger par
des pratiques risquant de lui porter
gravement atteinte
nous avons voté la loi accompagnant asv
de 2015
d'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement dans une logique de
confiance de souplesse et de convergence
tarifaire faut-il aujourd'hui examiné
cet état d'esprit nous espérons que les
auditions d'aujourd'hui permettront
notamment d'apporter une réponse à cette
question je demanderai à chacun d'être
concis et dans les questions et dans les
réponses et je vais maintenant
conformément à la procédure applicable
commission denquête vous demander de
prêter serment je rappelle que tout
témoignage mensonger devant une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire est
puni de cinq ans d'emprisonnement et de
75000 euros d'amendé le philippe
charrier prêté serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et dj
monsieur jean christophe rault merci
il faut mettre le micro oui oui alors
remettez le micro pour dire je
[Musique]
le jure monsieur jean christophe rault
merci prêté serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité levé la main
droite et des jo le jure je le jure
alors messieurs seriez vous avez la
parole pour un propos liminaire de dix
minutes de maximum avant que je ne la
donne en rapportant plus haut
commissaire qui souhaite vous interroger
nous souhaite en effet que cette option
soit très interactif donc un propos
cours pour introduire ensuite les
rapporteurs poseront des questions et on
aura ainsi un jeu de questions réponses
à suivre très très très courte je vous
passe tout près merci madame la
présidente madame monsieur les
rapporteurs mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs le 30 janvier dernier j'ai
accepté de prendre la direction générale
du groupe orpea dont je présidais
jusqu'à lors le conseil d'administration
parce qu'il était indispensable de
permettre à l'entreprise de continuer à
assurer sa mission dans les meilleures
conditions
je me suis porté volontaire pour faire
face et assumer les responsabilités
éthiques morales et juridiques de notre
groupe dans ce moment difficile alors
que je n'y étais pas tenu et que les
candidats n'étaient pas pléthore
j'ai fait ce choix simplement en
responsabilité parce que je suis
attachée à cette entreprise et ce
collectif de 70000 personnes à la suite
d'une histoire personnelle qui m'a
permis d'en connaître la valeur et l'
expertise notamment dans
l'accompagnement des personnes les plus
fragiles une connaissance aussi au
regard des questions de cicatrices
décisive aujourd'hui pour le bon
fonctionnement de nos sociétés mais
aussi pour l'accompagnement du grand âge
je les fais parce que cela me paraissait
relever de mon devoir vis-à-vis des
familles et de leurs aînés qu'elles ont
choisi de nous confier dans cette
mission si difficile mais essentiel qui
est la nôtre celle de l'accompagnement
en fin de vie de personnes souvent très
âgées fragiles c'est dépendantes selon
le rapport jeandel guérin 80 % des
résidents d pad sous prend des faits de
troubles de la cohérence des
comorbidités aggrave leur état souvent
sans qu'il puisse le réaliser du fait de
la noce oddo cie qui est fréquente j'ai
fait se joue aussi parce qu'il était de
mon devoir de protéger et de défendre
l'honneur et la fierté de l'ensemble de
nos collaborateurs qui ont choisi de
réaliser au quotidien ce métier exigeant
en rejoignant les rangs d'orpea dans
l'un des 1000 établissements que nous
opérons dans 23 pays
depuis plusieurs semaines nous sommes
pris dans la tourmente
fin janvier a paru un livre à charge des
fossoyeurs suite à une enquête de trois
ans dont je n'ai appris l'existence que
le 23 janvier dernier le 1er février
cinq jours après que le conseil
d'administration d'orpea est lui même
mandaté deux cabinets d'audit
internationaux pour faire toute la
lumière sur les allégations contenues
dans cet ouvrage le gouvernement a
annoncé de son côté le lancement d'une
double enquête confiée à l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales et à
l'inspection générale des finances
avant même que nous n'ayons pu faire
valoir nos droits au contradictoire sur
le rapport provisoire en 48 heures
étendue à huit jours ouvrés à notre
demande nous en découvrions la semaine
dernière les conclusions dans la presse
nous avons reçu le rapport définitif le
27 mars enfin le souper en parallèle des
contrôles s'intensifient sur nos
établissements qui font l'objet de plus
de 150 visites d'inspection depuis la
fin du mois de janvier soit sept fois
plus en deux mois quand une année
normale ce qui n'est pas choquant en soi
dans le contexte émotionnel et politique
crée le gouvernement le samedi 28 mars à
sur la base du rapport de la mission
deux inspections publié un communiqué
annonçant notamment le signalement au
procureur de la république conformément
à l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale des faits relatifs aux pratiques
pointé dans les rapports d'inspection
tôt nous contestons la matérialité il
résulte de cette circonstance que
certains fait que nous sommes appelés à
examiner aujourd'hui seront très saine
of très certainement également analysées
par le parquet et peut-être par un juge
d'instruction je n'ai pas d'inquiétude à
ce sujet au contraire je crois à
l'efficacité
du travail dans le donjon à l'examen
approfondi des faits par des experts et
aux vertus du contradictoire mais ces
circonstances mais mènera peut-être à
m'exprimer avec prudence sur certains
sujets par exemple la question d'usagé
notation publique qui comme nous le
verrons un sujet très technique qui
dépasse très largement le cadre b en l2
manifestement lieu à des interprétations
notamment de la doctrine comptable qui
peuvent varier je prendrai donc soin sur
ces questions vous le comprendrez je
l'espère de m'exprimer avec prudence
afin de ne pas interférer avec les
investigations sont en cours j'ai en
effet pleine conscience de l'importance
cardinale de votre émission et de la dea
nécessité d'offrir une totale
transparence devant la représentation
nationale
mais je ne veux pas me livrer à des
appréciations qui pourrait dépasser mes
compétences et mettre en danger plus le
groupe que je représente avec cette
exposition factuelle du déroulé des
résultats événements tels que nous les
avons vécues vous désirez sans doute
l'ampleur du choc qui nous a affectés
même si je mesure parfaitement en
parallèle l'émotion que ces informations
ont pu susciter aussi dans les familles
de résidents dans le grand public et
auprès des élus et des pouvoirs publics
les faits qui nous sont reprochés sont
graves et j'ai conscience par conséquent
de l'exigence de réponse et d'action
attendu de ma part ainsi 2 ainsi que de
celle de monsieur jean christophe
remercie notre directeur général pour la
france présent à mes côtés devant vous
ce matin
je me suis régalé en est avec moi les
collaborateurs d'orpea la gravité la
souffrance l'émotion la colère mais
aussi la stigmatisation et l'opprobre
que chacun d'eux subie à tout instant
depuis des jours des semaines alors
qu'ils doivent prendre soin des aînés
que nous leur confions
je ne vous dirai pas que groupe dopés à
na rien à sur vos propres au chai je ne
vous dirais pas que nous sommes
coupables de rien
la mission conjointe de ligier fait
digas à la suite de la publication du
livre nous a fait des reproches est si
grave et pour sapin nous avons répondu
point par point à ces questionnements
légitimes nous avons reconnu des
dysfonctionnements pour certains est
inacceptable même si le rapport
définitif permet de conclure qu'il n'y a
pas de système organisé qui aboutirait à
une maltraitance généralisée et dément
clairement les allégations les plus
jeunes au compte du livre nous
regrettons profondément ces
dysfonctionnements et nous tenons à
présenter nos sincères excuses ou
résidents et leurs familles mais il ya
dans ces attaques et ces reproches
beaucoup de choses inexactes et injuste
et c'est aussi notre devoir de le dire
de les démontrer comme nous l'avons fait
dans les réponses au rapport de la
mission conduite par les deux
inspections
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
seront je l'espère l'occasion pour le
groupe de nous expliquer et de nous
défendre mais aussi de nous avant dé et
de prendre des décisions pour repartir
de l'avant
ma tâche est ma responsabilité sont de
sortir le groupe orpea de la tourmente
dans laquelle il est plongé aujourd'hui
tous les reproches ont cédé 6 régularité
qui ont pu nous être ou qui nous sont
reprochés les noms certains sont avérées
trouveront des réponses et des solutions
changement de comportement changements
parfois de lignes directrices et bien a
vendu
vous confondre nous conformerons à toute
injonction administrative et judiciaire
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir une
limiteront pas nos efforts à réagir ou
nous défendre dès aujourd'hui
j'annoncerai une série de mesures
précises et concrètes pour rétablir un
fonction ici un fonctionnement efficace
et fiable d'orpea vis-à-vis de toutes
les parties prenantes et ainsi redonner
confiance à nos résidents c'est leur
famille à nos salariés aux pouvoirs
publics et à nos actionnaires ces
mesures sont la première à morne amorce
d'un plan plus vaste de transformation
du groupe que nous allons annoncer en
mai prochain à la lumière des résultats
de nos audits externes
le sujet du vieillissement de la
population de la dépendance et de la
perte d'autonomie sont des sujets de
débats et d'intérêts nationaux vous le
savez mieux que quiconque puisque sur
les territoires dont vous êtes les élus
vous êtes en contact régulier avec des
maisons de retraite et des
établissements de santé consacré
beaucoup de temps et d'efforts ils vont
bien au-delà du cas d'orpea qui ne peut
être le bouc émissaire de toutes les
difficultés du secteur je remarque
d'ailleurs que dans sa communication de
samedi matin le gouvernement engage un
mouvement visant à renforcer les
contrôles la transparence et la qualité
pour l'ensemble des et patrie les et
public
nous sommes face à un enjeu de société
majeur je vous sais suffisamment
expérimentés et vr visé pour savoir que
les sanctions éventuelles contre orpea
où les mesures de correction que nous
allons être amenés à prendre ne vont pas
régler tous les problèmes associés
aujourd'hui à l'accompagnement en fin de
vie de nos idées
soyez assuré en revanche que nous
entreprendrons
de notre côté tous nos efforts pour
apporter notre contribution à
l'élaboration des solutions de demain je
me tiens à votre disposition a vengé
avec jean-christophe remercie pour
répondre à vos questions
merci et je laisse tout de suite la
parole à l'orateur qui commence
je vais commencer merci madame la
présidente de mécénat pas mal merci
d'être venu effectivement de répondre à
notre audition enfin vous saviez pas
trop le choix il faut le dire mais je
pense qu'il était important qu'on puisse
vous entendre et je voudrais rappeler
tout de suite quelque chose
notre mission n'est pas vis-à-vis du
rhdp à aller pour l'ensemble des
résidences pour personnes âgées en
particulier on regardera toutes les
résidences qui sont privés à but
lucratif mais c'est pas orpea uniquement
qui est visé je voudrais quand même vous
pousser tout de suite une question à
vous monsieur charrier dans l'entretien
publié par le journal le figaro du 26
mars vous déclarait nous regrettons que
le rapport définitif ne soit ni rendue
publique ni mise à la disposition des
parties prenantes seront auditionnés
hier la ministre déléguée chargée
l'autonomie qui nous a déclaré que le
gouvernement souhaitait rendre public le
rapport igas igf mais que cela n'était
pas possible du fait de l'opposition
d'orpea opposition réitéré dans un
échange de courriels entre l'ami ces
deux groupes que nous avons eu de la
part la ministre ce matin ma question
est simple la société orpea autorisait
la publication du rapport de la mission
igas igf sur la gestion des
établissements d'hébergement de
personnes âgées dépendantes du groupe en
perte je vous demande oui ou non
simplement
monsieur le sénateur bernard bernard
bonne bien sûr que oui nous n'avons
jamais sollicité la non publication de
ce rapport jamais
écouté je crois que les choses sont
claires c'est s'est dit sous serment
tant que ça veut dire que des deux mains
le rapport plus pourrait publier enfin
en respectant bien entendu de secret des
affaires o le secret est sincère vous
savez monsieur le sénateur se limite
tout simplement à ce qui relève du droit
de la concurrence un exemple simple nous
n'allons pas mettre le détail de tous
nos contrats oui mais mais tout le reste
mérite absolument être largement
diffusée très bien mais je vous remercie
c'est une précision à comptant alors
maintenant au sud sur leurs ailes bien
entendu vous avez reçu un nombre de
questions sur lesquelles nous vous
demanderons des réponses écrites
assez rapidement et on va essayer de
poser d'autres questions puisque celle
là à la nuit de vous y répondre et déjà
mais on voulait quand même vous reparler
de l'intérêt de la mission aujourd'hui
ses désirs ya eu des failles il des
failles au niveau 2 de toutes les
parties prenantes de vous en particulier
puisqu'elles sont reprochés aujourd'hui
du reste vous nous direz pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous n'allez déposé aucune
plainte contre l'auteur du livre les
fossoyeurs et puis vous dire aussi que
il faut absolument que nous trouvions
les moyens aujourd'hui de voir pourquoi
les contrôles ont n'ont pas rempli leur
rôle
comment les mettre en place correctement
et quelles sont les solutions qui
pourraient être préconisées à la suite
de notre rapport en juin que nous
rendrons en juin après avoir fait toutes
nos auditions cc première question que
je voudrais vous poser et auxquelles je
souhaiterais des réponses
monsieur le sénateur bonne temps dans ce
rapport il y a deux types de
dysfonctionnements
d'ordre financier
d'une part et
d'ordre de prise en charge
très largement attribuable à un manque
constant de personnels soignants des
détenus et quant au rôle quand on lit et
j'ai lu attentivement la déclaration de
monsieur beau trouve ici
toute la partie
du rapport
igf igas ne fait que confirmer ce qui
est dit dans le rapport de la cour des
comptes que vous avez eu la grande
pertinence madame la présidente de de
réclamer c'est un outil qui nous aide
beaucoup merci d'avoir fait
voilà maintenant
au niveau de la diffamation nous
essayons d'être le plus professionnel
que possible nous avons mandaté deux
cabinets de renom international de façon
à pouvoir répondre à toutes les
allégations du levant nous aurons dans
les jours qui viennent la réponse est
sur cette base nous déciderons ce qu'il
convient de faire à l'égard
d'une diffamation d'ores et déjà vous
savez que bien des allégations du livre
se sont avérées inexactes infondée à la
mission le dis j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer à ce sujet
bien
vous avez terminé pour la réponse
c'est toutefois si je sois j'avais pour
lui à vos réponses moi j'ai terminé on
reposera la question je faisais
moi je me propose de dérouler le
questionnaire que vous avez hu et donc
d'aborder les questions de remises de
fin d'année de rationnement et de
qualité d'accueil des résidents donc
selon le monsieur castanet le groupe
orpea a organisé un système de
rationnement des repas désigné sous
l'acronyme crj et donc vous avez recours
à des compléments alimentaires pour
pallier la dénutrition des résidences
qui frapperait un tiers d'entre eux au
sein de vos établissements d'abord
est-ce le cas et puis pour s'appuyer
nous appuyer sur ce qui a été dit lors
des précédentes auditions à l'assemblée
nationale monsieur leumann d'une part
monsieur brun d'autre part parle bien de
se
crj et
voilà donc c'est une organisation
quand même on peut le dire et est ce que
vous confirmez donc cette mise en place
dès rationnement journalier
président malam la sénatrice
meunier je propose que jean-christophe
remercie qui a été à la fois directeur
d'ehpad
directeur régional avant de prendre sa
responsabilité de directeur général très
récemment un c'était en fin d'année 2021
puis je vous réponde précisément vos
questions
madame la sénatrice michel meunier merci
pour votre question
le crj existe mais il n'est pas le fruit
d'une décision immédiate vous parlez
nous parlons là de nutrition de
personnes âgées en situation de
dépendance de d'états dépressifs très
souvent et de troubles cognitifs
j'ai été effectivement directeur
d'établissement
pendant des années puis directeur
régional également j'ai été auprès des
équipes auprès de résidents auprès de
familles notamment pour mener ce travail
fastidieux qui est le sujet de la
nutrition dans un ehpad à l'entrée la
moitié des résidences rançon dénutri
avant d'entrer dans l'établissement
et nous nous devons évidemment de faire
tout ce que nous pouvons pour améliorer
l'état du trésor des résidents nous
accueillons ce que nous arrivons à faire
à une année après deux des deux tiers de
ces personnes
nourrir des personnes âgées en situation
de dépendance avec des pathologies
différentes avec la nécessité de
textures différentes avec des régimes
différents
le diabète par exemple relève de
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
concertation
nourrir des personnes âgées c'est un
travail collectif qui part du médecin en
passant par le chef de cuisine les aides
soignants les auxiliaires de vie qui les
accompagnent c'est toute une chaîne de
travail de responsabilité de
collectivités pour pour y arriver
comment comment établissons nous
les menus nous partons du besoin avant
toute chose il y à des recommandations
de la has de lancer de l'ansès
parle des apports en protéines haute
énergétique et qui sont nécessaires avec
des recommandations que nous suivons
nous appliquons ces recommandations
basées sur les apports nécessaires
sur la base de ces recommandations
un travail est établi entre des médecins
nutritionnistes chef de cuisine nous ne
traitons pas la restauration tous les
chefs sont salariés et tous les repas
sont produits dans les établissements à
partir de ceux de ses recommandations
des menus sont établis sur cinq semaines
avec quatre cycles correspondant aux
saisons l' équilibre alimentaire
protéines énerve calories et de ce fait
travailler au sein de ses menus
une fois que ces menus sont établis et
bien seulement à partir de là il s'agit
d'aller constituer les achats qu'ils
correspondent et ce crj dont vous parlez
qui veut dire qu'aux résidents jour
ne parle que de la partie alimentation
il faut savoir qu'en france dans les
ehpad orpea nous servons plus de 13
millions de repas par an et que de ce
fait les négociations avec des
fournisseurs qui ne sont pas la grande
distribution mais des fournisseurs en
amont permettent d'obtenir des tarifs
qui sont effectivement qui peuvent
apparaître comme ça surprenant et
interrogés mais qui sont le fruit d'une
négociation basée sur un volume mais
avant toute chose sur la base des
besoins
ce serge et alimentaire il doit être
considéré également avec les salades et
des cuisiniers les personnes qui
concourent au service à la cuisine et
les matériels également ce sont comme
l'avait dit jean claude braud donc plus
de 15 euros 14 euros par don en 2018
hors taxes qui concernait les frais
payés à la production des repas mais
encore une fois sur la base de des
besoins concernant les compléments
alimentaires puisque vous évoquez cette
question là
lorsqu'une personne est en situation de
dénutrition
alors ça son alimentation est enrichie
elle est enrichie de manière naturelle
avec de la crème du fromage etc et puis
si nécessaire en cas de dénutrition plus
sévère de compléments nutritionnels oro
qui font l'objet d'une prescription
médicale et qui viennent en complément
des repas la dénutrition est suivie et
nous luttons contre la dénutrition de la
manière suivante en suivant la lbu mines
l'indicé de masse corporelle la perte de
poids dans le temps des pesées mensuel
qui sont réalisées et en cas de
dénutrition une surveillance plus accrue
de l'alimentation et des pesées sebdo
madère ce que l'émission igas igf ont
relevé également merci de votre réponse
monsieur le directeur général moi je
veux simplement vous remettre le
contexte ici nous sommes dans la
commission des affaires sociales avec
des sénatrices et sénateurs des affaires
sociales ça veut dire que sur leur
territoire la commune le département ils
ont exercé des responsabilités dans le
médico social on va dire pour faire
large et dans le grand âge
particulièrement il y a ici des
personnes qui ont été présidents de
conseils d'administration des fans donc
nous savons ce qu'est un ehpad son
fonctionnement nous savons les
difficultés et le profil nouveau des
résidents accueillis c'est vrai depuis
quelques années donc voilà ça vous
épargnera peut-être de la pédagogie que
nous avons
ici en commun sur ce sujet et sur la
question des repas j'y reviens est ce
que vous confirmez le chiffre de 4 euros
73 73 pour être précis dans la bouche de
monsieur de brink 4 euros 60 13 hors
taxes pour confectionner ce repas
journal mans avec ces dernières les
quatre les quatre heureux pas les quatre
à cinq en comptant la collation
madame la sénatrice
excusez moi d'aller voir si j'ai été ce
revers la pédagogie je vous présente des
excuses mais ces jeux je les ai vécus
quotidiennement pendant des années
effectivement alors c'est un certain
coût alimentaire hors taxes de 4 euros
80 aujourd'hui
encore une fois il faut partir des
besoins et considérer les la négociation
lié à 13 millions de repas servis chaque
année nous avions en 2018
effectuées sur la base de nos menus avec
un constat d'huissier à l'appui
des cours dans des anciennes de grande
distribution et la différence de tarifs
avec des enseignes de grande
distribution était de l'ordre d'un peu
plus d'un euro par rapport à ce que nous
nous pouvons obtenir comme tarifs
complétée par ce que j'ai sous les yeux
là dans le rapport igas igf le
comparatif entre les des valeurs le
groupement d'étude marché en rétention
collectif gm rcn que vous connaissez
certainement et les européens et on voit
nettement qu'il ya une différence de 10
20 voire 30% entre les recommandations
faites au niveau de la nutrition en
général et celle que vous mettez en
place au niveau européen c'est pour
cette la question était posée est ce
qu'il ya vraiment une volonté de réduire
drastiquement la nourriture alors en
connaissant tous il ya beaucoup de
médecins ici on en sait des difficultés
d'approvisionnement les difficultés de
de nutrition des personnes mais voilà ce
qu'il y a vraiment cette volonté de
réduire au maximum le coût journalier de
la nourriture mais monsieur le sénateur
bernard bonne la réponse est non vous
avez vu que nous avons répondu
abondamment
aux aspects sur la nutrition du rapport
de façon très complète je tiens un
rapport là bien évidemment toutes nos
réponses à vos dispositions la question
est non nous ne ratio non pas
absolument pas aujourd'hui près de la
moitié des résidants qui arrive en ehpad
sont dénutris la moitié d'entre eux la
moitié d'entre eux il faut le savoir et
et un an après les deux tiers d'entre
eux on retrouvait un profil bien
meilleure il n'y a pas de rationnement
je n'accepterai jamais de rationné la
nourriture de nos aînés d'un engagement
sous serment est formel que je prends
ici
j'en profite on profite pour poser une
question pour les posera de façon rapide
mais c'est vrai que l'on ne veut pas
trop de détails en veut surtout des
réponses un peu claires alors sur les
sur les rétrocessions dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure on a beaucoup parlé des
rétrocessions qui était faite par
bastide hartmann des laboratoires les
laboratoires de d'examen et je voudrais
vous nous expliquer un peu un moment
vous nous avez dit non non il n'y a
jamais de ré fa dans nos établissements
puis après abbassi et des raies fin mais
ça correspondait à des prestations de
services alors il faut m'expliquer parce
que on a tous été responsables de
collectivités ou autre et on a eu des
rêves enfin on n'a pas eu d rfa on a eu
les réductions de prix quand on acheter
certains produits il y avait pas d rfa
qui venaient en contrepartie et crf and
cfa si elle existe les prestations de
services à quoi correspondent tél et
est-ce qu'elle était vraiment utilisé
pour les résidents puisque c'est de
l'argent public qui était donné pour les
résidents et est ce que vos prestataires
vos fournisseurs ont le choix très bien
de dire oui ou de dire non
enfin
monsieur le sénateur bernard bonne
madame la sénatrice michel meunier chez
répondre à ces questions
nous avons arrêté les choix nous n'avons
pas de réponse nous utilisons ce qu'on
appelle des prestations de services à la
mission a considéré que certaines
prestations services et être un
précisément décrites dans les contres en
fait une appréciation qui est dans notre
sens discutable
quel est l'objet de ces prestations
services y en a plusieurs chez vous
donner un exemple le premier qui est
très utile à à nos résidences et le
développement de nouveaux produits
par exemple nous travaillons avec
hartmann sur des changes connectés nous
travaillons et bastide sur un nouveau
matelas anti escarres il y a des
éléments qui sont maintenant au
catalogue de ces sociétés qui n'existait
pas avant j'en profite de dire que
l'allégation du livre scandaleuse
qui prétendait que nous des gradients la
qualité des changes pour économiser de
l'argent est absolument hausse
au contraire nous avons listé le change
le plus coûteux que nous fournissait
notre
arman en l'occurrence dont c'est
exactement la verse et j'en souffre
auriez-vous gens souffrent de de lire
sans voilà voilà ce qu'il en est
maintenant deuxième type de protestation
s'est on peut aider des fournisseurs
comme bastide à s'internationaliser
nous sommes présents dans 23 pays de
lachine jusqu'au brésil et est bien
évidemment c'est une prestation service
qui est très apprécié de la part de nos
footing de fournisseurs
malgré cela nous avons décidé d'exclure
désormais de l'assiette du calcul des
redevances dues au titre des prestations
de services le montant des commandes de
produits du secteur de soins et de
dépendances j'ai pris cette décision
tout simplement qu'il n'y ait plus de
questions là dessus voilà encore une
fois notre volonté c'est le soin parce
que effectivement bon ça nous a posé
beaucoup de questions au niveau de tout
ce qui n'était pas uniquement crois
qu'elle s'est pas les seuls à avoir
pratiqué ce ce type de rétrocession mais
ce qui nous semble anormal qu'il y ait
des rétrocessions pourquoi pas mais
qu'elles servent au niveau des résidents
et pas à d'autres choses que pour les
résidents puissent rester d'argent
public alors que vous les arrêter
maintenant oui enfin ces deux matches et
c'est c'est dommage que vous vouliez pas
fait de jeu je n'arrête pas les
princesses en service ne vous méprenez
pas je dis simplement je les écarte de
l'assiette pour éviter la confusion mais
mais ses prestations services
demeureront puisque je voyais y
précisément elle peut permettre
d'améliorer l'accueil des résidents
voilà
je regrette compléter la part parce que
vous venez dire sur vous aider en
soutien à l'internationalisation de nos
fournisseurs mais est-ce que c'est au
forfait dépendance de soutenir cette
internationalisation est ce que vous
pouvez clarifier un peu ce qu'il ya
derrière parce que sinon si enfin à
courcy ça peut être ça peut être
compliqué à défendre puisqu'il ya déjà
des dispositifs publics de soutien à
l'export donc est ce que vous entendez
par par exterminateurs enfin
internationalisation de vos fournisseurs
et bien ça permet des économies
d'échelle considérables
et des réductions de coûts tout aussi
forte aujourd'hui quand on compare nos
prix par exemple des changes au prix de
trouver dans internet c'est moins 45%
si vous voulez comparer au prix des
grossistes qui fournissent les
établissements de santé l'écart est
entré entre 13 et 21 % voilà l'économie
d'échelle maintenant est ce que j'ai
bien reggiani question à laquelle je
n'ai pas répondu madame astrid soigner
vous disiez mais est-ce qu'ils ont chois
questions très pertinentes
portman voyez vous nous représentons
nettement moins que 1% de leur chiffre
d'affaires
voilà qu'ils ont vraiment le choix
terminer avec ces c'est flatteur c'est
au niveau des laboratoires on a été
étonné effectivement dans le livre les
fossoyeurs les laboratoires d'analysés
médicales est ce qu'ils sont est-ce
qu'il est avéré comme dans le livre que
les choix n'ont pas plu était effet
comme auparavant c'est à dire que vous
choisissiez les laboratoires en fonction
des rétrocessions ou des des réductions
enfin qu'il faisait sous quelle forme se
faisait et pourquoi les laboratoires
locaux ont été un peu écarté la plupart
du temps des examens qui pourrait près
par les établissements
sénateur bernard bonne écartons
des fournisseurs pour obtenir
plus d'argent la réponse est non c'est
pas la volonté de la société pas la
vente et la société je connais un peu la
biologie médicale puis avoir beaucoup
travaillé dans ma vie j'ai dirigé un
groupe de biologie médicale européen
les prestations services existent il ya
des mises à disposition d'un certain
nombre d'équipements maintenant pourquoi
travailler avec des grands groupes de
biologie médicale ce qui est le cas je
n'aimerais pas ici je ne ferai pas de
bonne publicité pourquoi parce que notre
échelle et en national avoir un
fournisseur qui puisse répondre à tous
nos besoins nationaux c'est une à la
fois une simplification et une plus
grande efficacité
si je voudrais ça va simplement pour
laboratories écrit quelquefois il est
quand même plus pratique d'avoir
admirateurs juste à côté et pour avoir
aussi exercer la médecine avoir un
laboratoire à côté qui permet de
répondre immédiatement aux demandes que
le médecin peut faire la sauce qui
détonnait les les grands groupes n'ont
pas là ici sont que des moyens
supplémentaires ils sont pas la
proximité suffisante je vais laisser à
chanter stuff monsieur le sénateur bonne
le soin de répondre je voulais vous
dites vous dire vous connaissez
infiniment mieux que moi toute la
médecine à vous est pas un je ne suis
pas que je veux vraiment clarifier les
choses
monsieur le sénateur bonne
les laboratoires de biologie médicale
qui se sont regroupés également et qui
est parfois constituent des groupes sont
néanmoins à proximité des établissements
et ce sont des laboratoires de biologie
médicale qui sont proches des
établissements
moi je me suis pas occupée ni de
relations contractuelles et de quoi que
ce soit avec le moindre des laboratoires
par contre ce que j'ai pu auxerre
observée notamment pendant la crise
sanitaire que nous avons traversée
c'était que effectivement de pouvoir
aussi avoir une discussion au niveau
national nous permettait aussi d'avoir
un meilleur service au niveau local
parce que si nous rappelons la crise
sanitaire les tests koji de nécessaire
les rt pcr tout ce que cela représentait
dans la dans l'accompagnement des
personnes dans les ehpad a été
extrêmement difficile et tout le monde
manqué de tout rappelons nous de cela et
notamment la proximité des laboratoires
mais qui appartiennent à des groupements
nous a permis d'obtenir de meilleurs
services au profit de nos résidents une
plus grande réactivité et c'est surtout
de celle de la vente il s'agissait
peut-être
veuillez m'excuser pour cette longue
réponse à votre question
ce qui s'est passé en biologie médicale
partout dans le monde
et en france un peu plus tardivement
c'est la consolidation du secteur quelle
était l'idée
l'idée était de construire des plateaux
techniques qui alimentait un grand
nombre de laboratoires la loi le
permettait donc nous contractons avec
des laboratoires qui restent
indépendants régionaux très locaux mais
grâce un groupe plus grands ils peuvent
faire leur analyse
des plateaux techniques très rapidement
c'est la nouvelle construction du
système
maintenant concernant le taux
d'occupation de vos établissements
avez-vous des taux d'occupation
supérieurs à 100 % comme on peut le lire
dans le livre de monsieur castanet
madame la sénatrice mais celle menée
concernant cette suroccupation qui est
mentionné dans le livre
vi j'ai fait du gaz seront analysés ces
éléments évidemment et nous avons aussi
pu prendre la mesure réelle de ce dont
il s'agissait
il n'y a aucune suroccupation programmés
ou demandé et cela n'a jamais été dans
mes pratiques et ça l'est encore moins
depuis que je suis en direction général
d'orpea en france là le taux
d'occupation et les surcapacités peuvent
résulter de situations qui peuvent
arriver qui parfois ont fait l'objet
d'ailleurs d'une information auprès des
autorités mais qui aurait dû le faire
systématiquement évidemment il y à des
personnes qui sont dans nos
établissements en court séjour avec un
retour à domicile qui est programmée il
y à des personnes qui viennent visiter
leur peu leurs proches viennent visiter
par bonds et une entrée est programmée
dans l'établissement et parfois il se
peut que la personne qui devait sortir
ne sort pas parce que le retour à
domicile n'est pas possible parce que
finalement elle veut rester un peu plus
longtemps parce que les dents naturelles
n'a pas repris les forces pour
l'accompagner à domicile mais l'entrée
elle était programmée et dans ce genre
de circonstance pendant une semaine
quelques jours il peut y avoir cette
surcapacité que qui devrait être
déclarée évidemment et qui ne l'a pas
toujours été
s'il y a eu des consignes locale eh bien
nous les dénonçons et nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec cela dernier point je
voudrais vous dire c'est que la
surcapacité au sein des établissements
d'orpea en france sur l'année 2019 qui a
été la base de deux ligas dans cette
analyse
la surcapacité représente
0,016 % des journées facturées
cela pour vous démontrer effectivement
que ça ne fait pas l'objet d'une
politique mais d'une exception
0,016 % entendu monsieur le directeur
général de vos propos sont notés et
notifiée c'est vrai que c'est étonnant
puisque par expérience c'est souvent des
taux inférieurs à 100 % qui sont
constatés fait de comme vous l'avez
expliqué des maladies d hospitalisation
voire décès
oui m'excuser mais c'est un triste
mettez-vous d'apporter un complément
les taux d'occupation sont les suivants
chez nous ou 27/03 2022 86% ou 31 12
2010 21 86 % au 31 18 20 joueuses de 90%
sia kambou effectivement je répondais
simplement inférieur à
alors je vais vous donner 31 12 2010 à
si vous permettez 92%
voilà non parce que effectivement bon
pour avoir connu ça dans tous les
départements
le taux d'occupation en règle aussi les
difficultés que peuvent avoir ou pas
d'établissement et c'est pour ça que je
sais que chaque établissement a tout
intérêt à voir un taux d'occupation
maximum est ce que la politique qui
était posée la politique du rhdp a était
de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait jamais
de taux d'occupation inférieurs à un
certain chiffre alors
monsieur le sénateur bones dont les
perdre et les ressources sont attribués
pour une norme de 95% donc c'est
intéressant oui le paddock sacré
paradoxe
nous avons nous parfois
sous budgété du fait de la modulation
parce que nous n'étions pas à 95%
preuve en est que la moyenne est à 92%
ou 31 12 2010 9 mai en même temps fort
nous fait le reproche se dire mais
comment pouvez-vous sont budgétés et
donc il ya un vrai sujet là il ya un
vrai sujet
dernière question concernant la qualité
de l'accueil dans les établissements les
conseils de vie sociale est ce que
chaque ehpad à son conseil de 8 social
qui fonctionne avec leurs représentants
des usagers leurs familles des
personnels également des noms commencent
à face
alors le conseil de la vie sociale dans
chaque établissement est une obligation
avec une fréquence minimale de 3 par an
et effectivement nous demandons et nous
regardons si les conseils de la vie
sociale sont constitués tels qu'ils
doivent être comme cela est exigé par la
loi un représentant des familles un
représentant des résidents comme vous
l'avez mentionné la direction etc
oui les conseils de la vie sociale sont
constitués fonctionne-t-il tous
exactement comme il le devrait parfois
une est malheureusement un poste est
vacant il faut organiser de nouvelles
élections parfois et notamment pendant
la crise sanitaire les conseils de la
vie sociale ont eu beaucoup plus de mal
à se réunir à l'occasion de nos
contrôles internes nous vérifions ce
point là et 80% des conseils de la vie
sociale était parfaitement conforme lors
de nos contrôles il est un point
d'amélioration si vous me permettez une
suggestion et j'ai toujours moi
souhaiter c'est que le penser la vie
sociale peut se réunir à huis clos a
simplement avec les représentants de moi
par exemple j'ai toujours fait en sorte
et j'ai toujours prôné et demandé aux
équipes de le faire de manière ouverte
pour ce soit beaucoup plus participatif
pour que l'ensemble des familles
puissent y assister l'ensemble des
résidents également et au delà des
conseils de la vie sociale je voudrais
vous mentionner aussi qu'il existe la
commission d'animation qui permet de
présenter les projets d'animation de les
travailler aussi avec les différents
représentants et des résidents en
premier lieu évidemment et puis les
commissions de restauration puisque les
menus dont variante à leur sont
présentés discutez peuvent être amendés
modifié en respectant l'équilibré
alimentaire pour répondre aux goûts des
personnes pour ce sont des institutions
et des instances extrêmement importante
et nous pensons qu'il est nécessaire
d'en renforcer la représentation
je voudrais aborder maintenant les que
les problèmes un peu financier de
contrôle parce que en fait d'une mission
elle cherche à regarder comment on
pourrait établir des contrôles qu'ils
soient plus effectif et puis là on voit
d'avoir ce qui est la difficulté on a eu
l'impression d'une odeur des groupes
comme orpéa c'est que les contrôles ne
se font que ne se feront pas au niveau
du groupe ils sont animés d chaque
établissement offre votre système ne
permet pas d'avoir des éléments
suffisants au niveau de chaque
établissement puisque tout est réglé au
niveau régional et c'est pour ça qu'à au
niveau des ars il faudra certainement
modifier les choses parce que les rs ne
peuvent pas contrôler un groupe et
contrôlent mal chaque établissement et
il ya une certaine opacité qui n'est pas
souhaitable et vous ne parlerez aussi de
la halle à l'autonomie suffisante des
directeurs d'établissements qui ne nous
sont pas effectives aujourd'hui donc
déjà à ces questions pour le contrôle au
niveau du groupe qu'est ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
nécessaire de modifier complètement ses
contrôles et puis après je vous parlerai
aussi la loi sv et des inconvénients
avantages qu'elle a apportée par ce que
la loi sv est allé dans le sens une
grande confiance au dos des
établissements avec la mise en place des
ces pommes et autres et puis un danger
quand même on l'a vu au niveau 7 os wc
que la confiance a permis certaines
dérives dont vous êtes obligés aussi
aujourd'hui et vous l'avez constaté tout
à l'heure
monsieur c'est un terme aux dérives il
faut qu'on puisse en discuter d'espacé
mais mes aides sur le sujet des
contrôles nous pensons que les contrôles
locaux sont très utiles pour la prise en
charge très utile
il faut les conserver et et dès que nous
avons les rapports de contrôle on prend
soin de mettre en place des
recommandations qui y figurent nous nous
sommes bien évidemment pas du tout
opposés à des contrôles au niveau du
groupe
nous nous y prêtent aurions très
volontiers
écouté que puis-je rajouter on efface
monsieur le sénateur bonne à
une réglementation très complexe on
pourra y revenir mais il faut rentrer
dans les détails
dans le détail
des choses est
difficile de faire un budget dans une
société en octobre novembre quand on
connaît le résultat l'approbation des se
perdent et un fin juillet par exemple
voyez comment faire d'autant plus qu'à
le facteur de modulation qui est là
comme anticipé dans le cadre de la loi
de l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement
la modulation tarifaire qui a été bonne
et tous ces sujets sont des sujets
infiniment complexe à mettre en place
pratiquement
tout à l'heure en parler en parler aussi
du personnel et c'est vrai que les
effectifs de personnel sont déterminés
par les départements et par la rs or ce
nombre de personnels et bien précis
alors que saddam dire c'est difficile de
trouver des personnes notamment pendant
les périodes de creux vide mais ça
j'allais dire je ne veux pas l'entendre
tout le monde a les mêmes difficultés
par contre au niveau du personnel je
voudrais que je m'affirme y ait ici que
les au niveau des ressources humaines
est ce qu'il y avait une volonté de la
part du groupe au niveau régional ou
peut être au dessus de dire ne remplacez
pas telle ou telle personne
lorsqu'il ya des absents un absentéisme
par maladie ou autre ou de vacances est
ce qu'il y a eu des des
demandes officielles de la part du
groupe au niveau des établissements de
ne pas remplacer toutes les personnes
dans le cas des vacances de
l'absentéisme ou de maladie
il n'y a pas de volonté de ce type au
niveau du groupe je ne suis pas
conscient d'un seul email direction je
parle de direction du groupe qui donne
ce type de consignes j'en ai vu aucun
absolument au niveau de la direction
générale du groupe il ya eu des erreurs
monsieur le sénateur bonne il y a eu des
erreurs il y en a eu lieu alors
des exceptions juge préférer les
qualifiés d'exception et un nous allons
être et c'est tout l'intérêt d'ailleurs
de de ce qui nous arrive nous allons
être extrêmement vigilant à l'avenir
dans ce domaine je m'emporte absolument
car en extrêmement vigilant ceci étant
ceci étant nous avons de vrais soucis
société aide soignante
40 % de personnes en moins qui se
présentent aux concours
iliad il ya des vrais sujets vrais
sujets sains
pour préciser la question de mon
collègue est ce que ce qu'on peut lire
dans le livre de monsieur castanet quand
il parle des directeurs nettoyeur entre
lee mais ça fait partie des erreurs dont
vous que vous évoquez non
c'est cette une expression
dont il porte la responsabilité
leur apport igf il ya c'est extrêmement
clair à cet égard il n'y a jamais eu de
nettoyeurs c'est une expression toute
assez odieuse qui jette l'opprobre sur
soixante dix mille personnes à tort sans
aucune preuve bien sûr
je voulais savoir si vous avez ailleurs
en place des procédures qui
font que vous êtes content absolument
certain que les dépenses qui sont un
peut imputer sur forfait soins relève
exclusivement de dépenses de soins ça
c'est une question importante par
rapport à ce que le le forfait soins et
puis j'avais une question qui revient
plus au débat initial sur le la prise en
charge mais dans livry les ennemis que
les certains établissements dans la
prise en charge et l'accueil de deux
résidents qui relève par exemple de la
psychiatrie c'est que c'est un sujet
auquel vous êtes
attachés nous l'avait dit en
introduction
que ces critères d'accueil certains
établissements sont peu regardants c'est
ce que délivrant trimestre sur ses
critères d'accueil et c'était c'était
l'autre qu'est ce que ça fait
madame la présidente catherine de roche
deux choses
le rapport
igf igas nous dit que 50 millions
d'euros ont été imputés sont heureux à
tort
dans un lit budget soins et dépendance
qui représente sur la période considérée
1 milliard 400 millions d'euros
simplement pour vous donner 100 de
vendeurs dans ces 50 millions une grosse
part vient des auxiliaires de vie comme
en fonction ou des soignantes voilà
c'est le sujet et c'est un sujet dont il
faut parler je crois que le rapport de
la cour des comptes est extrêmement
claire dans ce domaine et vous le
connaissez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs parfaitement bien pour être
prêt vous savez que voilà c'est une
chose que
je pense que orpea doit progresser je
pense qu'on peut apprendre et à
progresser je pense par exemple que
l'écart de salaire entre aussi un devis
aides soignants bien suffisante si elle
est mon opinion donc on le voit
travailler dessus on va travailler sur
les carrières mais c'est un pc un vrai
sujet c'est un vrai sujet le deuxième
élément que je vous donne qui est le
deuxième gros ajustements et ça ça c'est
l'essentiel de la différence on
l'essentiel de la différence il est très
technique voulez-vous gens parlent ou
préférez vous que je réponde à vos
questions ultérieurement
non non non non non ça ça concerne la
cvae est ce qu'on doit ou non imputée la
cvae à la dotation soins la cvae est une
taxe sur la valeur ajoutée si par
exemple si par exemple les
personnels soignants
qui sont financés par les dotations
était mis à notre disposition
nous n'aurions pas à payer une taxe sur
la valeur ajoutée n'aurait pas d'uv que
ces personnels soient rémunérées par les
opérateurs cela crée une taxe sur la
valeur ajoutée naturellement est ce que
les sociétés doivent la prendre sur les
profits comme un coup où doivent être ou
doit-elle être imputée ou 2 c sans soins
la justice est saisie nous verrons nous
répondrons à toutes les questions mais
c'est un vrai sujet
on est tout à fait d'accord là dessus
simplement pour revenir alors à des
choses plus basiques j'allais dire
pourquoi un tel turn over au niveau des
directeurs pas du personnes à haut
niveau des directeurs c'est tout à
l'heure en disait qu'il n'est pas
directeur nettoyeurs on veut bien
l'admettre et pourquoi autant de tours 9
je reprends et pourquoi pourquoi les
beaucoup de directeurs se plaignent un
peu justement de ce turn-over
important
concernant le turnover des directions à
ce jour nous avons quatre postes vacants
de direction sur l'ensemble des
établissements en france et le turn over
est de 12%
cette année sept ans oui cette année
nous avons regardé évidemment tous ces
éléments là dure l'ancienneté moyenne
des directions d'établissement charpail
de cette année le turnover est de 12% je
vous le dis et je je je ne vais pas
faire trop long mais j'ai été directeur
d'établissement j'ai été un jeune
directeur qui ne connaissais pas le
métier j'ai été accompagné par un
directeur régional par une équipe qui
pouvait m'accompagner j'ai eu un appui
sur des procédures des procédures qui
venait du terrain de l'expérience
d'orpea mais qui m'ont permis
d'apprendre mon métier ils ont pu me
guider c'est un secteur qui est
infiniment humain mais également
infiniment réglementé est complexe et le
travail d'un directeur est extrêmement
compliqué donc étant des salades en gros
on connaît bien des directeurs je
voulais simplement vous attendez qu'elle
est justement la formation qui a demandé
à vous directeur tout parce que
rendements beaucoup au niveau des
directeurs dans le public on en demande
une certaine aux niveaux déprimés
associatif mais qu'elle est vous ce que
vous demandez ce que vous exigez de la
part du directeur
monsieur le sénateur bernard bonne ce
que nous exigeons de la part des
directeurs c'est conformément à la loi
de disposer d'un master 2 qui concerne
le secteur lorsque nous avons des
personnes qui ne disposent pas et bien
les accompagnons dans une formation ils
ont un poste de directeur adjoint et
puis ils évoluent mais chacune de nos
directions dispose du master 2
conformément à la législation
tous sans exception
et pour ceux qui ne le serait pas serait
temps en cours de formation pour
l'obtenir pour être en conformité
parce que le diplôme est extrêmement
important mais a aussi l'aptitude l
envie de faire ce métier et quand des
personnes dont la petite sud et l envie
de le faire eh bien il est notre devoir
de les accompagner pour obtenir le
diplôme qui permettra de l'exercer
oui juste oui mesdames est présent on va
poser dans quelques questions puis après
je crois que tous collègues devront en
vous aidant ceux ci n'auront pas le
temps les deux questions s'il faut on
reviendra
j'allais vous dira aussi si ça ne suffit
pas parce que le rapport igas igf on l'a
eue lundi 500 pages sincèrement j'ai pas
le temps de lire complètement j'en suis
à la page 185 90 mais je le lirai
complètement pour voir un peu il y aura
peut-être d'autres questions posées je
voudrais quand même vous poser des
questions très précises et si vous
pouvez pas me donner des réponses
aujourd'hui je voudrais absolument
savoir pas écrit
je voudrais savoir le nombre de lits
c'est donc lé nombre d'établissements
qui ont été créés depuis 2005
scheer paix à ceux qui ont été créés ou
ceux qui ont été rachetés
mais précisément et ceux ci on pouvait
me donner même de enfin très exhaustive
mais d'en haut niveau de la france 1
ceux qui ont été créés ou racheter je
voudrais aussi savoir et la ccn un peu
différent combien de personnes avez vous
embaucher au niveau du siège ou ailleurs
au niveau du rhdp a qui étaient des
fonctionnaires venant de la rs ou des
départements
de façon exhaustive depuis une dizaine
d'années
combien et puis en me disant ou
instituts bien entendu et quelles
fonctions ils ont un
monsieur
avec des fonctions oui bien entendu mais
les précisions parce que cette question
a été posée hier à la ministre on pense
que c'est quand même quelque chose qui
pose problème
c'est une bon c'est une clarification
qui me faut importer pour être certain
on n'accuse personne mais je voudrais
pas qu'on soupçonne les connivences
entre les uns et les autres y compris au
niveau des départements mais qui pas de
connivence entre les uns et des autres
monsieur le sénateur bonne nous avons
pris bonne note nous allons répondre
précisément à cette question
il ya bien évidemment la part
d'européens aucune volonté d'établir des
connivences un fileyeur les rapports de
d'inspection de la rse montre bien à
leur lecture que bon
mais nous nous répondrons très très
précisément à ces questions sachez que
nous n'avons pas il ya bien longtemps
que nous n'avons pas acheté de
d'établissement et pad en france on
n'est pas on n'est pas acheteur me
regarder le marché enfin le marché je
devrais dire le secteur c'est pas notre
carence porte pas cher
mais c'est à toi nous le serons voilà
donc moi je vais peut-être arrêter là
sur les questions qui étaient préparés
vous répondrais et organiste si nos
collègues et moi j'ai une question vous
nous avez dit en début de l'audition ce
qu'on a pu lire dans la presse que vous
a annoncé des mesures à venir et
notamment des enquêtes des enquêtes de
qualité c'est ainsi qu'elles sont nommés
fait par des
[Musique]
cabinets renommée
indépendant alors en trois packs et
qu'elle en quoi ça consiste qu'est-ce
que quel est ce qu est la nature de ces
de ces enquêtes et quel est le degré
d'indépendance vis-à-vis de votre
conseil d'administration de groupe orpea
l'origine de ces enquêtes c'est quand le
conseil d'administration a découvert le
23 janvier au soir 19 heures d'existence
une longue enquête depuis présent j'ai
tout de suite réuni un conseil
d'administration le 24 janvier et
nous avons voulu comprendre
les allégations du ive était terrible à
notre égard et donc notre volonté était
d'apporter une réponse
total à toutes les allégations du livre
on ne peut pas tout les reste ce genre
de choses bien évidemment ça a été
l'objet de
de ces enquêtes nous avons mandaté des
cabinets de réputation mondiale parce
qu'elles ont une éthique et elles ne
peuvent en aucun cas se permettre de ne
pas répondre à leur démission lors de
missions aura été écrit par un avocat
extérieur spécialisé même pas par le
conseil nous nous voulons passer de leur
démission nous font passer tout à fait
que le fit dans l'émission et nous
serons dans quelques jours
les résultats
voila voila c est l'objet de toutes les
questions dit absolument toutes les
questions du doubs ma réponse à votre
question précédente sur la diffamation
pour des questions alors
laurence cohen ensuite rené paul savary
élisabeth doineau laurence cohen
oui merci messieurs
je pense que c'était important de
souligner comme l'ont fait mes collègues
rapporteur bernard bonnet et michel
meunier il n'y a pas que le groupe orpea
qui doit être
sue qui doit être sous l'éclairage et je
pense que de toute façon vous l'avez dit
nous avons interrogé effectivement la
prise en charge de nos aînés et
notamment
autour des ehpad mais pas que voilà on
est tous et toutes un jour amenés à
vieillir quand je l'espère et en bonne
santé j'espère encore davantage et donc
il faut que les qualités d'accueil soit
soit au rendez vous moi j'ai plusieurs
questions où vous avez parlé
monsieur charrier de recours à deux
cabinets de renommée
internationale pour faire
pour aller plus loin dans les enquêtes
j'attire votre attention sur le fait qu'
il y à une commission il ya une
commission denquête au sénat sur le
recours intempestif au au cabinet et je
pense qu'il faut être extrêmement
attentif à cet aspect là des choses et
je vous je vous encourage effectivement
à à le faire parce que c'est pas parce
qu'on a recours à des cabinets de
réputation mondiale on l'a vu avec mc
kinsey mais là encore c'est peut-être là
un petit cache la forêt que c'est
beaucoup d'argent pour pas grand chose
donc ça c'est ma première remarque
deuxième deuxième remarque mon collègue
bernard bonne vous a parlé de remises de
fin d'année rfa notre collègue député
pierre dharréville qui est coauteur
d'une mission flash concernant les ehpad
à l'assemblée nationale un a
souligné cet aspect là des choses et le
journal les échos critiquer je cite un
pilotage par la masse salariale
préjudiciable à la qualité de prise en
charge des résidents ayant abouti à un
cumul de 20 millions d'euros de dotation
non consommés en quatre ans entre 2017
et 2020 je reprends donc le journal les
échos et ma question c'est est-ce que
vous allez rembourser ses 20 millions
d'euros à la sécurité sociale
ma deuxième question c'est concernant
les pratiques
que vous avez souligné la façon dont
lesdites des directeurs étaient recrutés
formés vos difficultés par rapport aux
personnels notamment soignant mais les
échos que nous avons pu avoir finalement
c'est que et ça a été souligné devant
nos collègues députés une nouvelle fois
c'est que les organisations syndicales
du groupe korian ont été unanimes lors
de ses différentes auditions pour dire
que finalement votre groupe était une
zone de non droit pour les résidents
mais également pour les droits les
droits syndicaux recours aux cdd abusifs
licenciement également abusif pratiques
anti syndicales etc pour qu'une
entreprise fonctionne il faut qu'il y
ait effectivement des contre pouvoirs de
la démocratie pour pouvoir justement
échanger discuter et améliorer les
choses donc j'aimerais avoir votre votre
votre commentaire là dessus et
sur le rapport cgt cfdt qui a été
commanditée au sik tard cabinet d'études
spécialisé en analyse fiscale
les deux organisations donc
dénonce démontre que votre groupe a créé
une casquette de sociétés au luxembourg
afin d'y transférer la propriété des
murs d'une bonne partie de vos
établissements est-ce que vous
reconnaissez avoir eu recours à
l'optimisation fiscale afin de ne pas
payer d'impôts en france et puis même à
ma dernière question remarque c'est
c'est quand même le fait qu'on a tous
été choqués par ce qui a été dénoncé
dans le livret par des témoignages que
nous avons pu les ans je me souviens
avoir lu je crois que c'était dans le
monde
la famille de françoise dorin qui est
morte dans des souffrances terribles
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de matériel et
notamment de matelas anti escarres donc
je vais dire il ya quand même des
manques qui ne sont pas seulement des
diffamations comme vous le soulignez et
du coup en pleine pandémie en 2021 votre
groupe a versé 58 millions à ses
actionnaires et a décidé d'attribuer un
parachute doré de 2.7 millions d'euros à
l'ancien pdg monsieur yves
à nous le mas n'a je ne sais pas est-ce
que vous ne trouvez pas que c'est
indécent et que finalement parler d'eux
parce que vous l'avez dit mot vous a
échappé puis vous êtes repris vous avez
parlé de marché moi c'est ce qui me gêne
c'est à dire que
utiliser le mot marché et finalement
faire des profits sur leurs grilles 1
c'est à dire les personnes nos aînés il
ya quand même quelque chose d'indécent
alors il n'y a pas que votre groupe mais
votre groupe en fait partie
oui
la sénatrice laurence cohen je voudrais
d'emblée clarifier une chose que je
parlais de marché pour les fournitures
et quand on achète des gens qui changent
de table les choses comme ça ça a marché
je parle de secteurs quand il s'agit des
pad ou de missions ce qui est beaucoup
plus approprié priorité à l'accueil vous
avez raison madame la sénatrice je
dirais simplement voyez vous nous
accueillons un profil de résidents très
très différents je les dis dans mon
propos liminaire on parler par exemple
de nutrition tout à l'heure vous savez
des résidents qui arrivent chez nous
pour la moitié
souffrent de dépression déprime se
nourrir est déjà difficile
indépendamment complètement des
quantités qu'on leur donne et de là on a
vraiment des sujets d'adaptation à des
résidents qui souffrent beaucoup de
maladies neurodégénératives actuellement
alors maintenant sur vos questions
précisément les les deux l'appeler deux
cabinets écoutez il c'est de bien
répondre aux allégations c'est des
actionnaires qui vont les payer voilà
donc ce serait à la charge des
actionnaires considérant que la
réputation d'une société et son plus
grand capital
l'airé fâche je m'en suis expliqué les
20 millions d'euros d'excédent
ne sont pas du tout traduire les profits
c'est neutre je les ai écrites redmond
neutralité on a passé une une écriture
comptable pour les neutraliser donc
l'argent est toujours à la disposition
voilà selon les réglementations en cours
y a pas un centime qui a été perçu par
les actionnaires
ensuite
s'agissant d'arc en ciel écoutez arc en
ciel le rapport de la mission
ne nous impute pas de tort dans ce
domaine là
il n'y a pas eu de contestation
particulière
à cet égard donc ce syndicat a été créé
par deux anciens membres de fo est-ce
qu'il faut plus de dialogue syndical
chez nous je réponds oui et j'ai donné
des instructions très claires dans ce
sens je veux ouvrir le dialogue social a
tout à tous les représentants syndicaux
quelle que soit leur taille donc nous
allons progresser dans ce domaine je
pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup mieux et
je me suis engagé
au niveau du sitar on l'a répondu c'est
yeux des questions complexes sita a
lui-même conclu qu'il n'y avait pas de
de fraudes dans notre système au
luxembourg nous avons effectivement des
essais aucun bâtiment établissements 1
français n'y est logé aucun n'a pas
voilà c'est simplement des actifs
internationaux par exemple des actifs
que nous pouvons avoir en allemagne qui
ont été logés au luxembourg c'est
parfaitement conforme à la loi il n'y a
pas de sujet particulier en tout cas ça
n'entache en rien les les impôts qui
serait dû au niveau des des opérations
françaises nous n'avons pas payer de
dividendes aux actionnaires lors de la
crise coded nous sommes la première
société à avoir décidé de pas payer de
dividendes les héros aulas était ce
héros nous sommes les premiers à l'avoir
annoncé à l'époque
maintenant s'agissant de monsieur jean
claude bourdin qu il avait un contrat
est un contrat
ce contrat nous l'avons respecté
ça a conduit à
un paiement qui correspond à deux ans de
rémunération ça a été approuvé par
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires
comme ici comme il se doit
madame à saint brice et je répondu à vos
questions est ce que voulait rajouter un
complément
je voulais simplement précisé quand vous
faites référence aux 20 millions d'euros
d'excédent ses 20 millions d'euros c'est
une somme extrêmement importante et je
reviendrai pas sur sur l'aspect
financier mais ce que je voudrais
ajouter c'est que ces 20 millions
d'euros représente sur les années
excédentaires
ramené au nombre de postes qui n'ont pas
été mis en oeuvre dans les
établissements à
0,56 tp par jour et par établissement en
moyenne ce qui veut donc dire pour des
taux d'occupation que monsieur charest a
rappelé tout à l'heure de 92% au plus
haut en 2019 et des taux inférieurs à 90
% donc c'est 20 millions d'euros
interpelle choc mais ils ne représentent
que 0 56 e tp pas rétabli mance pense
que je voulais vous préciser concernant
également une partie extrêmement
important les ratios d'encadrement et
épais haussière de vie aides soignants
aide médico psychologique etc
nous faisons dans le cadre de le perdre
et vous le savez bien une prévision qui
donnait un ratio d'encadrement et au
moment d er r&d donc le 30 avril de
l'année suivante - déclaration d des
moyens utilisés les taux d'encadrement
que nous avons déclaré madame la
présidente peut le voir juste là dans
les oeufs rrd les taux d'encadrement ont
toujours été supérieure aux au prd
toujours été supérieur et enfin parce
que vous parlez du livre effectivement
mais ce rapport et monsieur le sénateur
bonne vous ont indiqué en faire une
lecture approfondie et assidu et c'est
extrêmement important la mission igas
igf page 58 2 révèle elle même que les
salaires pratiqués au sein du groupe
orpea correspondent à ceux du secteur et
sont même légèrement plus haut je vous
remercie madame ce peut être une
dernière précision qui peut être utile
sur les 20 millions d'euros pourquoi des
excédents ses excédents ont eu lieu dans
les deux dernières années donc au type 2
est de -1 21 et 20 c la crise co-lead 1
c'est le résultat de la crise qu vide et
voyez bien au taux d'occupation à 80 6%
julian 2001 de 86 ans 21 88 en vain on
était très en dessous des européens d un
père d
île voilà
c'est mécanique ces deux années donc
quand on regarde les deux années du
passé on était soit en pertes soit à peu
près à l'équilibré
on a on a vécu il faut le dire quand
même on a oublié ça on a vécu deux
années qu vide terrible dans les ehpad
on ne pouvait pas vous pouvez pas
hospitaliser nos résidents rappelez vous
quand même des choses orpea a été la
première société à acheter des masques
au prix fort en chine un mois avant
qu'il soit livré partout ailleurs on
savait pas si on allait être remboursés
on a acheté massivement des protections
donc
ne l'oublions pas
quand on parle de 20 millions moi j'ai
donné un exemple aussi sur les matelas
anti escarres avec le témoignage de la
famille de françoise dorin mais il doit
y en avoir beaucoup d'autres c'est très
choquant que dans un établissement haut
de gamme donné comme étant le nec plus
ultra les résidents sont soit traitée
cette façon là parce que si dans ce
genre d'établissement ils sont traités
comme ça on imagine dans les autres
établissements qui sont moins
prestigieux non madame la sénatrice mme
laurence cohen oui vous c'est tellement
délicat de parler le secret médical
le médecin
bonne qui était juste à côté de moi
baballe comprendre je vais être prudent
nous avons demandé à un juge
de désigner un expert justement médical
pour pouvoir examiner chacun des cas
2 dt allégations de monsieur castanet ça
nous a été refusé on l'a demandé parce
qu'on voulait avoir des éléments nous
nous partageons vraiment par un bien
évidemment les allégations du you ça
nous a été refusé on verra quelle autre
procédure nous pourrons entamer à cet
égard le taux d'escarres la mission le
dit elle-même nous n'avons pas plus
d'escarres chez repérer plus tôt - la
mission retrouver que le soin de vue là
nous faisons un bon travail
moins d'être car ça veut dire aussi que
la nutrition n'est pas si mauvaise que
ça m'est donc ça a été constaté
voilà mes mais il nous apporterons toute
la lumière sur ces événements en dernier
lieu madame la sénatrice évidemment que
si un matelas anti escarres n'est pas
adaptée ou bien positionné et bien ça
n'est pas normal et nous devons y
remédier ce n'est pas l'objet d'une
volonté mais d'erreurs mais qui doivent
ne pas exister
veuillez m'excuser à madame région il
faut des réponses tout est roulement
au népal savary
oui merci
merci
vous l'avez dit monsieur président
directeur général un secteur infiniment
humain est complexe
et vous auriez pu rajouter financiers
d'ailleurs pour reprendre des propos de
laurence cohen
quand vous avez dit regardez le marché
c'était sur la question des rachats
d'établissement c était pâle sur la
question des moyens par établissement
donc effectivement il ya un marché de la
personne âgée autant le reconnaître on
est là pour un non pas juger mais pour
agir dans la transparence et la
sincérité et on pourrait avoir
l'impression qu'il peut y avoir des
dérives de par le système ou des erreurs
vous avez confié qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'erreurs vous avez pris beaucoup
d'engagements à cette audition ce qui
montre bien qu'il y avait des
dysfonctionnements
pourquoi pas avoir pris ses décisions
avant c'est que vous êtes lucide dans la
situation qui a effectivement des
dysfonctionnements donc on pourrait
penser que vous avez établies ou que
d'autres ont établi je ne veux pas jouer
progrès a donc on peut penser que dans
le secteur médico social pour les
personnes âgées il peut y avoir une
industrialisation
de cette prise en charge
avec des directeurs qui ont un titre des
directeurs par établissement mais qui en
fait pourrait être déterrées acteurs
adjoint des filiales au service du
groupe plus qu'au service des personnes
âgées de leur établissement
on peut penser que avec le dispositif de
perdre et de calculs par établissement
de gier moyen pondéré pour prendre en
charge la dépendance des personnes
prises en charge par les départements
on arrive à faire en sorte avec ce que
vous nous avez expliqué les achats
notamment
de d'avoir des l'argent
tiré de l'apa qui remonteraient au
niveau des groupes
donc ça voudrait dire que finalement
l'apa est versée aux personnes est
calculée par établissement par moyenne
est finalement trop élevé dans ce type
de structure puisque on arrive à faire
en sorte de générer des bénéfices en ce
qui concerne le forfait soit également
pourrait penser que le forfait soins est
trop élevée puisque j'ai l'impression
qu'avec le rapport que vous avez eue
avec les biologistes vous arrivez à
remonter de l'argent de par la prise en
charge des soins le forfait hébergement
là aussi on a l'impression qu'un certain
nombre d'établissements peuvent faire de
l'argent avec les forfaits hébergement
donc
pensez vous que cette industrialisation
et vraiment l'évocation de ce secteur
ne pensez-vous pas également
qu'il va falloir que les choses changent
de façon
très profonde pour éviter que certains
puissent dérivés dans ce type
d'industrialisation du dispositif est ce
que vous confirmez
cette volonté d'action financière en
plus de votre volonté largement affirmé
de prise en charge humaine des personnes
âgées
messieurs le le sénateur savory quelques
éléments de réponse sur
l'industrialisation
c'est un métier l'humain on
industrialise pas l'accompagnement de
fin de vie c'est très impossible à oprah
passant ce cap à sens
l'accompagnement de fin de vie c'est un
métier extraordinairement difficile
humainement
on s'attache aux résidents on les voit
partir c'est un métier très dur donc en
aucun cas il s'agit d'industrialisation
ce dont il s'agit c'est groupé les
moyens groupe et les moyens le rapport
de la cour des comptes le dit très bien
il dit que compte tenu des difficultés
de ce secteur
des groupes ont des capacités plus
grande différence et le rapport de la
cour des comptes recommande ce type de
deux démarches maintenant y at il une
volonté si nancière jeu une série de
notre métier le banc le rendement vous
parler sinon ce on ne recherche pas le
rendement c'est pas un métier ou
chercheur en ont en 2020 par exemple le
rendement sur les capitaux propres s'est
élevé à 5 % voilà sinon le bilan 5% donc
je pense que nos actionnaires ne cherche
pas le rendement il cherche une
croissance régulière et une récurrence
voilà c'est beaucoup plus si vous voulez
leur leurs objectifs en espérant avoir
répondu à vos questions monsieur
sénateurs
sabots de bois nommé ensuite jean sol
élisabeth doineau oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président
directeur général monsieur le directeur
général
le livre les fossoyeurs nous a tous
évidemment choqués mais au delà du choc
il y a aussi les témoignages comme le
disait ma collègue laurence cohen de ces
témoignages bouleversants 1 que
nous avions presque du mal à imaginer et
en même temps ce choc cette crise qui
est en fait
créé suite à ceux à ce livre document eh
bien on est tous les uns les autres en
tant que société face à nos
responsabilités
ça veut dire que comme le disait je l'
ai entendu madame la présidente tout à
l'heure
la silver economy c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne devrait plus utilisés comme
terme parce que se faire de l'argent sur
le dos des anciens pour moi c'est
quelque chose d'inacceptable mais
vraiment inacceptable si je vais en
économie c'est c'est un terme qui m'a
toujours hérissé et je pense que
aujourd'hui on ne dénonce quelque peu à
travers ce livre témoin
j'ai juste de questions vous savez dans
les établissements quel qu'il soit c'est
très difficile pour une famille de
dénoncer une maltraitance qu'elle
soupçonne et souvent elle ne le fait pas
par peur des brimades des anciens qui
sont dans les établissements cependant
il y en a qui osent y en a qui osent
voir le directeur y en a qui osent en
parle à une infirmière qui est plus dans
l'empathie que d'autres ou une aide
soignante
mais que faites vous vous des plaintes
qui vous arrive est ce qu'il y avait un
protocole est ce qu'il y avait une
charte de finalement deux prises en
compte donc ça c'est ma première
question ma deuxième question est ce que
vos établissements faisait l'objet de
démarches qualité de façon interne
démarche rse donc de responsabilité
sociétale des organisations parce que ça
c'est souvent l'occasion de remettre
tout en cause aussi bien des parties
prenantes qu'ils soient fournisseurs
résidents familles achat comportement
et d'opel ce que vous faisiez ce genre
de démarche entre établissements comme
c'est fait par exemple dans le réseau
ouvrage donc habitat jeunes et on sait
que ça prend du temps pour les salariés
ça prend du temps pour les uns et les
autres mais c'est tellement une remise
en cause et qui fait du bien en termes
de qualité comme moi je me demandez si
vous vous en faisiez l'objet
pour tout vous dire je pense que ces
moments de
deux points de vigilance sur la qualité
de service en tout cas elle doit trouver
sa source auprès des résidents auprès
des familles mais aussi d'associations
extérieur de retraités
d'associations qui sont là pour aussi
mettre l'accent sur une maladie
dégénérative
il ya bref beaucoup de sources à
l'extérieur est ce que vous vous les
utilisez en quelque sorte parce que je
trouve que c'est très utile
de justement d'être aux côtés des
familles qui n'ose pas à côté des
résidents qui ne peuvent pas souvent et
il ya aussi toutes ces associations
comme
la défense du consommateur etc qui
pourrait être à vos côtés en tout cas
mes questions sont là quel traitement
des signalements et est-ce que vous avez
des démarches qualité au sein de vos
entreprises
madame la sénatrice élisabeth doineau
merci quand vos questions concernant
votre première question quant à la
dénonciation et à la remontée de plainte
de la part des familles nous avons oui
effectivement un protocole de traitement
de ces plaintes parce que nous devons
accorder la plus grande attention à
chacune d'entre elles concernant les
plaintes de deux tiers d'entre elles
sont adressés directement à la direction
de l'établissement mais un de sierre est
adressée soit la direction régionale
soit directement au siège quand une
plainte ce nous arrive nous d'abord
accusons réception de la plainte la
direction prend un rendez vous avec la
famille nous suivons le fait que la
direction est bien répondu si le
problème n'est pas résolu il peut être
parfois nécessaire que la direction
régionale également interviennent et
nous avons une personne spécialement
dédié à ce suivi la des plaintes par
contre il faut encore aller plus loin et
ça fait partie de nos de nos
propositions et nous avons monsieur
philippe charrier en a parlé nous allons
mettre en place un certain nombre de
dispositifs une ligne un numéro vert
mais pour déclarer toute remontée mais
avec du personnel et nous avons décidé
de mettre des personnes qui soit capable
d'écouter et de mettre des psychologues
à les routes et pas simplement des
personnes qui accuse réception d'un coup
de fil qui sont et bien sûr je ne
dénigre personne mais des personnes qui
ne seraient pas formés à ce qu'elle
écoute de la souffrance dont nous avons
choisi de mettre des psychologues et ce
sera effectif très prochainement nous
avons aussi choisi de mettre en place
des médiations avec un médiateur au
niveau de la france qui sera en charge
de ces questions quand les résolutions
ne sont pas possibles il faut aller plus
loin mais nous avions et nous prenons
évidemment toutes nos responsabilités à
cet égard concernant la démarche qualité
la démarche qualité existent depuis
vingt ans au sein du rhdp a et il ya de
nombreux critères qualité qui sont
évalués par les directions sur la base
de référentiels de protocoles de
procédure bien sûr mais qui concerne
aussi bien et en premier lieu les soins
d'accompagnement la prise en charge mais
également la restauration la partie
administrative l'hébergement les locaux
l'entretien des locaux la sécurité etc
je les connais extrêmement bien pour les
avoir mis en oeuvre beaucoup d'endroits
et suivi sa démarche qualité elle est
évaluée par les directions et leurs
équipes auto-évaluer elle fait l'objet
d'une évaluation aussi semestriels par
les directions régionales les directions
régionales n'agissent pas seules parce
que pour chaque direction régionale les
directeurs régionaux sont accompagnés
d'un médecin coordonnateur régional on
parle de la pénurie médicale et vous le
verrez nous avons eu nous 82 sites 82%
de sites avec médecin coordonnateur qui
est supérieur largement au secteur mais
néanmoins nous avons des médecins
coordonnateurs régionaux nous avons des
référents qualité régionaux nous avons d
infirmière coordinatrice régionale parce
que l'oeil externe est extrêmement
important parce que le danger c'est
effectivement le huis clos et c'est pour
cela que ses équipes existent nous
sommes engagés oui dans la rse nous
disposons d'une de fondation vous parlez
de l'engagement des personnes beaucoup
de nos salariés partout en france
s'engagent dans du mécénat de
compétences et nous mettons du temps à
disposition pour tous les salariés qui
le souhaitent
concernant nous sommes engagés auprès de
nombreuses associations parce que cela
fait partie de notre rôle et nous devons
encore aller plus loin et nous avons
augmenté les moyens destinés à ces aléas
de la fondation et à ses actions vous
parlez de se mettre en réseau et de ne
pas être dans l' isolement c'est
extrêmement important nous avons
travaillé par exemple avec france
alzheimer pendant de nombreuses années
ça ne il ya plus de dix ans je crée pour
la première fois
une soirée réunissant des professionnels
avec france alzheimer le chu des
professionnels de secteur et nous avons
mis en oeuvre des conférences qui se
sont généralisés un peu partout en
france pour parler pour ne pas être
isolé nous travaillons avec de
nombreuses associations mais je continue
notamment sur sur france alzheimer avec
le café des aidants parce que bien sûr
il ya les personnes que nous
accompagnons et que nous accueillons
mais leur et dans leurs familles leurs
proches mérite aussi toute notre
attention voilà les exemples d'éléments
que nous mettons que nous mettons en
oeuvre et puis vous pas aller parler
aussi de la de la
direction gérer la concurrence je crois
aux jeunes ce prix des vêtements mais ce
que je peux dire c'est que sur les
droits nous avons été aussi les premiers
à a signé avec la médiane de la
médiation de la consommation un
partenariat pour avoir des médiateurs à
disposition voilà ce que nous avons
entrepris mais nous savons et nous avons
conscience de devoir aller beaucoup plus
loin et simplement sur l'exercice et
l'autonomie de ce métier par nos
directions j'en ai été un et mon action
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et ce qui continuera
c'est de faire en sorte que les
directions d'établissement bénéficier
d'autonomie de confiance de travail mais
que nous continuons à les accompagner
dans un champ de responsabilité
extrêmement large et en respectant leur
travail comme toutes les équipes
juste une précision s'il puis mesdames
sénatrice isabelle boinot nos nos
enquêtes qualités sont faites par un
tiers
les familles
les résidents y participent donc ces
enquêtes elles sont vraiment
complètement indépendante de la
direction du groupe voilà et on a un
taux de réponse de l'ordre de 50% ces
enquêtes sont fait très régulièrement
tous les ans avec quand même 400
critères et à l'intérieur voilà
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur j'ai quelques questions
notamment concernant les ratios agents
lits et places sur lesquels vous vous
adosser pour prendre en charge les
résidents et en particulier la nuit
combien de personnels soignants pour
combien de deux résidents ont fait relié
vous évoquiez la le dispositif de
signalement en nous disant que deux
tiers étaient traitées au niveau de vos
direction un tiers étaient reportées si
j'ai bien compris sur les tutelles mais
quantitativement ça veut dire quoi est
ce que vous pourriez être précis et
enfin ma dernière question concernant
les postes dont dont vous avez besoin au
sein de nos établissements
est-ce que les pré requis en matière de
formation et de compétences sont
respectées ou pas puisque vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure sauf erreur de ma
port que vous remplaciez boidé soignante
par des auxiliaires de vie c'est pas du
tout le même métier donc or on peut
rapidement réaliser qu'en terme de deux
prestations de deux de fonctionnement et
de compétences mises à disposition des
résidents il puisse y avoir notamment un
certain nombre de failles je vous
remercie
pas en danger
je
sais vous permettez je vais répondre
rapidement sur les ratios des agents par
rapport aux places votre question par
bon c'était
concernant la nuit oui nous avons nous
avons coût de 80 % nos établissements
nous avons trois agents désormais la
nuit c'est une demande que nous avons en
fait auprès nos établissements et avant
même la réforme de la loi et ce biais de
la tarification ou à l'époque d'ailleurs
c'était donc le département les rs qui
fixait le nombre de 2,2 d'agents par par
nuit et il était souvent pour pas dire
tout le temps fixé à 2 et nous avions
décidé nous d'anticiper d'être à trois
et nous et nous voulons absolument y
être pour une personne dédiée notamment
dans les unités ou les personnes
souffrant de troubles cognitifs mais la
pratique a été pendant des années dans
de secteur 2 2 et nous devons aller vers
3 et peut-être même plus
alors les infirmiers de nuit on relevait
d'expérimentation et jusqu'à très
récemment elles ne sont pas généralisés
nous avons quelques endroits où nous
avons des infirmières de nuit soit dans
l'établissement soit mutualisée soit
d'astreinte les agents que j'évoque sont
des aides soignants deux aides soignants
et une auxiliaire de vie par nuit c'est
ce qui relève de la réglementation mais
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur
parce que les besoins de prise en charge
évolué largement avec le vieillissement
de la population la dépendance je vous
savez tout cela parfaitement concernant
les compétences et les auxiliaires de
vie
monsieur charles y faisait référence
tout à l'heure aux auxerre de vie qui
imputaient la dotation soit en disant
que nous avions reçu un milliard deux
cents millions d'euros de dotations
soins sur ces quatre années et ce qui
est imputée sur les auxiliaires de vie
le relève de 28 millions d'euros sur
l'ensemble dans ce n'est pas si
important que cela même si c'est trop
évidemment elles ne correspondent pas à
la description du cds mais quand un
directeur et directrice d'établissement
et le matin et que le manque du monde et
que la seule personne les seules
personnes disponibles sont des
auxiliaires de vie et bien ce qui compte
avant toute chose c'est d'apporter
l'accompagnement et le soin si je peux
me permettre juste un commentaire je
pense que nous devons être tous
collectivement nous le travaillons nous
au travers des aveux notamment mais
améliorer le dispositif de formation de
diplômes des auxiliaires de vie qui sont
en disposent de vm parfois échoué à leur
diplôme pour un simple module est que
nos bons nombres de compétences ds
pourrait être porté par des auxiliaires
de vie diplômés d'un niveau
intermédiaire peut-être pas sur tous les
modules comme le bac s et spay pro par
exemple qui donne cinq modules sur huit
voilà voilà ce que ce que je voudrais
vous dire par rapport aux soigneurs
j'espère avoir répondu monsieur le
sénateur
les trois
collègues alors alain dufour
c'est très vicieuse ce directeur merci
de nouveau réponse les collègues et les
rapporteurs effectivement maison me
faisait pas mal pas mal de questions
mais et n'oseraient pas davantage le
coup puisque il ya eu md des questions
précises sur les manquements et
dysfonctionnements que vous avez reconnu
au début de vos de vos propos
aujourd'hui vous avez évoqué monsieur
monsieur le directeur des changements de
comportement dans l'avenir ah non moi je
veux savoir en quelques lignes sous les
caisses qu envisagée mais gare aux
reconstruire et effet qu'est-ce que vous
avez jagr l'avenir c'est pour modifier
un peu votre façon de fonctionner et
notamment au niveau des établissements
l'assistanat sans qu'un distance daniel
[Musique]
c'est l'accord est sacré provençal
en tentant pas daniel
normes et on me colle maintenant
micro-ondes entend par le prix goncourt
de
la corrèze
je faisais le président du département
problèmes de connexion on n'entend
absolument pas on va passer tout de
suite
oui c'est bon
oui oui oui oui
[Musique]
ou non
il faudrait peut-être couper la caméra
mois va
tomber oui mais il faudrait couper la
caméra peut-être le sang sera meilleur
oui
je m'entendais un oui très bien et est
ce que vous m'entendez oui parfaitement
bon voila merci
merci madame la présidente non monsieur
le directeur écoutez on a aussi
l'habitude localement d'avoir pris en
charge dès des ehpad pour vivre et pour
accompagner des personnes âgées en ce
qui concerne le prix de journée
alimentaire c'est vrai que ça
extraordinaire parce que ça nous ait pas
de roue en payent moins de 1000 euros
par mois on une journée qui le double
toujours beaucoup devaient pas prendre
beaucoup de produits français pour
l'alimentation
autre question
vous avez dit que si pour il fallait un
laboratoire avec un taux technique
nationale pour l'efficacité dû
complètement faux on a souvent besoin de
l'analyse de bases et c'est bien d'avoir
un laboratoire en ximité en squeez que
vous dites que c'est pas un industriel
mais si parce que quand on accepte
un parachute doré comme ça il n'y a je
trouve que c'est complètement indécent
et je pense qu'il va falloir que dans
l'avenir notre société accepte
ce
changement est ma question est ce que
les directeurs au niveau régional ne
sont pas choisis pour avoir de la
rentabilité et enfin vous avez indiqué
que l'os commettait une auxiliaire de
vie en remplacement d'une aide soignante
sur le but ce soir eh bien ça ne
fonctionnait pas et que pour vous faire
faire remonter en bénéfices comme la
villa président d'une partie du budget
soit en bénéfices de l'établissement
c'est totalement faux on peut lorsqu'il
ya une absence des soignants la
remplacer par une auxiliaire
momentanément voilà j'espère que dans
l'avenir et liège nous aurons une
philosophie je veux pas prendre en
charge les personnes âgées en faisant de
l'argent sur le dos des familles ou des
perturbations
merci ben assassin est maintenant pour
terminer jean luc richer et ensuite
j'en écoute tu oublies bonjour 11 mars
mis au jour le jour bonjour à tout le
monde pour de la très bien très bien
très bien que mon maître donc rebonjour
ce2 de questions très simples la
première j'aimerais savoir quel est le
coût mensuel le faible qui est pratiqué
au sein d'air d'orpea et du coup quel
est le coût mensuel le plus élevé qu'il
ya au niveau 2 de
doper à thé et du coup ce qui justifie
la différence entre ces deux coups dans
la prise en charge des résidents ça
c'est la première question est la
deuxième question c'est est-ce que des
critères je vais vous avez d'évaluation
économique par établissement et est ce
que vous avez de même manière des
critères d'évaluation qualitative de la
prise en charge par établissement je
vous remercie
donc fin des questions et sur nes
répondent qu'ils commencent je peux
commencer
à répondre aux sénateurs alain alain
dufaut
qu'est-ce qu'on veut améliorer déjà on
est là
on est dans un secteur et une mission
qui ne peut pas atteindre la perfection
c'est une volonté de tendre vers cette
perfection mais il n'y a pas de de
vraiment de perfection dans notre note
secteur les grandes actions eux la
première c'est donner plus d'autonomie à
nos directeurs d'établissement sur
bourru sujet nous y veillons c'est un
élément est essentielle là la deuxième
chose c'est à l'égard de nos résidents
et des familles gros delà des études
qualitatives on leur demande leur
opinion
de façon indépendante par un tiers on va
aller plus loin on va mettre un numéro
vert pour les résidents patients les
familles les proches on va nommer des
médiateurs on va créer des comités
d'éthique et des comités d'éthique
proche des établissements il y a ensuite
au niveau des salariés nous voulons
progresser dans le dialogue social mon
âme beaucoup de choses je pense à faire
et nous allons commencer maintenant dans
ce domaine a on va travailler sur la
fidélisation des équipes et des parcours
professionnels
il ya il ya tout tout ce sujet de
politique de rémunération pour valoriser
justement les les parcours de carrière
nos soignants il ya une politique de
recrutement beaucoup plus de jeunes
talents on envisage de 2,2 prendre 500
apprentis aides soignants et on va
décentraliser notre fonction ressources
humaines vers les établissements vers
les régions voilà en quelques mots la
réforme je vais peut-être si je je peux
commencer ou préféré répondre aux
sénateurs niel chassaing une passante je
peux je joue
très bien alors y at il des produits
français oui bien sûr on achète des
produits français on a en a une on l'a
dit dès d'un très grand nombre de repas
de repas servis pour les laboratoires
écoutez j'ai j'ai entendu votre marque
on va l'étudier on va l'examiner a gelé
entendu
encore une fois on va donner plus
d'autonomie aux directeurs
d'établissements maintenant vous avez
évoqué le le traitement de
industriel parce que vous disiez que il
y avait une forte prime de départ qui
avait été versée vous savez il s'agit
d'un groupe mondial on est dans dans 23
pays
c'est le marché des dirigeants est ce
qu'il est et bien évidemment avec une
très grande complexité quelque part je
suis c'est assez heureux pour mon pays
crée une entreprise comme la nôtre
peut-être une forme de signature en
dehors de nos frontières puisque un
développement si rapide montre quand
même qu'on a pu apporter quelque chose
en dehors de france pour
l'accompagnement de noël de nos seniors
maintenant au niveau des directeurs
d'établissements et directeurs régionaux
la qualité c'est l'objectif numéro un
numéro un et d'ailleurs quand la qualité
n'est pas là et bien on supprime
immédiatement la moitié de leur bonus 1
pour des des aspects de rentabilité donc
de la qualité rien n'est plus important
je le répète c'est fondamental je laisse
à part peut-être pour répondre sénateurs
jon clichés oui merci monsieur charest
sur les pas pour monsieur pour monsieur
le sénateur alain dufour je dois
simplement précisé que les mesures
d'avenir qui ont été évoqués par
monsieur philippe charrier même si elles
se font aujourd'hui dans cette
disposition là ce sont des notions que
nous avons travaillé
ces derniers mois ces dernières années
c'est exactement l'objet de ce que je
veux porter dans l'entreprise accompagne
des équipes opérationnelles encore une
fois parce que je connais ce métier
parfaitement et je sais ce que méritent
les équipes dans l'accompagnement et
notre famille
je préciserai
à monsieur le sénateur daniel chassaing
que nous sommes inscrits évidemment dans
la loi et galim qui est en vigueur qui
fixe aussi des obligations nouvelles et
que nous avions été
entendu par le ministère en charge de
cette transition là pour savoir où nous
en étions et qu' il semblerait que nous
en étions à un stade plus avancé dans la
vie active 2022 que bon nombre d'entre
nous
concernant les directeurs régionaux
monsieur charrier vous a répondu
concernant les remplacements des
auxiliaires de vie madame la ministre
elle même l'a dit sur france inter
samedi matin que les auxiliaires de vie
pouvait être admis au vu de la pénurie
des personnels soignants en remplacement
effectivement et comme vous le dites
c'est ce que nous disons également et
c'est ce que nous faisons nous ne
remontons pas les postes vacants en
bénéfices nous avons des oscars de vie
qui pallie effectivement à toutes les
difficultés sectorielle du recrutement
des aides soignants monsieur le sénateur
jean luc fichet pour répondre à votre
question concernant le coût des
établissements
le tarif moyen en france dans les
établissements orpea est de 84 euros par
jour
nous avons jeu j'y arrive j'arrive
j'arrive tout de suite j'arrive tout de
suite nous avons 17 établissements dont
le tarif est inférieur à 2000 euros et
nous avons quatre établissements soit
1,77 % d'établissements dont le tarif
mensuel est supérieure à 6000 euros
+ 2
je vais recevoir le coût mensuel
pratiquer le plus faible dans un
établissement et le coût maximum que
vous prêts
le coup il va donc il faut alors je
compléterai ma réponse par des éléments
que nous vous transmettrons pour
répondre de manière très précise mais à
la journée et quand je parle d'âne ehpad
à 2000 euros par mois cela veut donc
dire que le tarif le moins cher de
soissons inférieur à 70 euros par jour
et quand on parle par exemple de
l'établissement de nuit mais ce ne sont
que quelques chambres qui sont de plus
de 50 mètres carrés qui arrive à des
tarifs supérieurs à 10 mille euros
voilà l'écart type je vous apporterai
bien sûr la réponse plus précisément
mais je vous dis que le nombre
d'établissements dont les tarifs sont
super estime d'euros par mois en france
sont au nombre de quatre enfin qu'est ce
qui constitue
ses différences de prix est bien moins
de la localisation et peut-être que
monsieur h harry pourra me compléter
s'il n'est pas été exhaustif mais quand
au rhdp a construit un établissement
l'achat du l'achat du terrain donc du
foncier la construction du bâtiment ne
relève d'aucun financement public
d'aucune aide et c'est l'entreprise qui
assure que cette charge là et vous
comprendrez évidemment que la charge
foncière et le prix au mètre carré sont
absolument différent qu'il s'agisse d'un
établissement dans le centre de paris ou
en province et en zone rurale et voilà
ce qui vient être une composante
importante du prix est ce que je
voudrais ajouter aussi c'est que nous
avons depuis dix ans en france et au
sens de la construction des études des
établissements de la rénovation des
établissements de la maintenance des
établissements parce que orpea a
regroupé aussi beaucoup d'établissements
qui étaient vétustes et d'ailleurs
madame la ministre et monsieur le
ministre vers ans ont annoncé des
mesures pour le secteur public orpea
depuis dix ans dans ses établissements
en france a investi plus d'un milliard
d'euros dans la construction la
rénovation la maintenance
l'amélioration des qualités d'accueil de
prise en charge d'accompagnement et de
travail pour les équipes bien évident
j'espère avoir répondu à toutes les
questions messieurs les sénateurs
questionné les critères d'évaluation
économique et
qualitatif
je vais compléter pardon alors si je
n'ai pas répondu comme nous l'avons dit
précédemment il y a dans les
établissements des critères qualités qui
font l'objet d'auto évaluation par les
équipes dans les établissements qui sont
vérifiées deux fois par an au travers
d'une vérification formelle en dehors de
l'accompagnement des équipes dont j'ai
évoqué les fonctions tout à l'heure
infirmière coordinatrice régionale
médecin coordonnateur régional référent
qualité régionale les critères
qualitatifs repose sur 4 100 points de
contrôle extrêmement large allant
évidemment du soin de l'accompagnement
de la prise en charge jusqu'à la
restauration l'hébergement les
conditions d'accueil le suivi des
dossiers administratifs le respect des
droits et libertés
le bon suivi des contrats de séjour des
contrats travail et c'est cet ensemble
là et vérifier tout au long de l'année
des plans d'actions sont établis en cas
d'écart dans un logiciel qui est
spécialement dédiée au suivi des plans
d'action avec des dates d'échéance est
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des inspections ou
de contrôle que nous avons dans nos
établissements sont également dans ce
plan d'action là et sont suivis par les
directions d'établissement leurs équipes
et les équipes d'appui régionalement et
comme le disait monsieur charrier les
cris des critères qualitatifs ne sont
pas atteints ils ont un impact immédiat
sur les critères de performance
financière de l'établissement parce que
il est absolument important que la
performance ne se fasse pas au détriment
de la qualité
merci beaucoup madame la présidente et
quelques mots de conclusion ces trois
minutes simplement madame la présidente
madame monsieur les rapporteurs à
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
voudrais simplement vous dire quelques
mots avant qu'on se sépare
vous remercier de la qualité de votre
écoute j'espère que nous avons répondu
le plus précisément possible à vos
questions et qu'on a été à la hauteur de
vos attentes
je mesure parfaitement le chemin qu'il
nous reste à parcourir pour redonner
confiance en notre groupe cela passera
par des efforts des explications des
réformes mais aussi par de l'innovation
et de l'initiative à cet égard je
voudrais vous faire part de deux
décisions que j'ai pris et qui vont
contribuer à donner la bonne direction à
orthez 1
la première est de maximiser la
décentralisation des décisions et des
responsabilités vers les établissements
de renforcer leur autonomie de nous
appuyer plus encore sur les directeurs
d'établissement les personnels qui
travaillent au quotidien pour les
résidents ce chantier va être
prioritaire pour nous nous allons
notamment entre autres améliorations
instaurait des médiateurs famille
rapprochée les comités éthiques du
terrain et améliorer le fonctionnement
de notre plate forme d' alerte
dans le même esprit la deuxième décision
que je tenais à vous annoncer
aujourd'hui c'est celle d'ouvrir les
portes de tous nos établissements et de
faire au mois de mai si l'aco vide le
permet une journée d' états généraux du
grand âge chez nous et dans chacun de
nos établissements résidents familles de
résidents élu membre de la
représentation nationale personnel
presse locale chacun sera convié à
participer à s'exprimer à débattre pour
faire émerger à la fois des critiques
mais aussi des solutions je m'engage à
ce que ce grand débat ait lieu partout
en france et soit suivie d'un
compte-rendu synthèse de propositions
concrètes dont tous les participants
seront destinataires ainsi que la
représentation nationale
à la rentrée la deuxième étape de ces
états généraux donnera lieu à une
réunion associe national associant les
représentants des parties prenantes
toutes les parties prenantes afin de
présenter des grands axes et des
propositions qui pourraient être menés à
bien précisément pour améliorer
l'accueil et la prise en charge et les
soins de nos résidents voilà comment
nous voulons procéder merci beaucoup
je voudrais je voudrais terminer encore
en conclusion un peu dire d'abord vous
remercier les réponses qui ont été
complètement différente de celle de
l'assemblée nationale et je crois que
c'est l'organisation de la présidente on
en avait discuté qui fait que poser des
questions avoir une réponse immédiate
était beaucoup plus intéressant que ce
que vous avez eu là bas parce que les
questions étaient intéressantes de
l'assemblée nationale les trop
nombreuses à la fois et vous ont pas
permis de répondre à tous et je voudrais
aussi dire que moi je voudrais remercier
avec vous victor castanet
parce que sincèrement s'il n'avait pas
écrit ce livre on n'aurait pas les
modifications qu'on attend à la fois de
vos groupes de niveaux bout privé à but
lucratif et aussi de la prise en charge
de nos aînés et j'espère que l'on va
déboucher enfin après nos rapports en
juin sur la loi grand âge avec des
moyens supplémentaires qui seront
affectés par tous parce que il ne s'agit
pas seulement de parler des difficultés
que vous avez au niveau de vos
résidences mais de toutes les résidences
pour personnes âgées je pense que ce
serait une très bonne chose
une question quand même en fait une
question je n'attends pas de réponse à
aujourd'hui mais vous aurez peut-être
d'autres questions écrites d'ici la fin
de notre mission à laquelle jours et
vous répondiez aussi sous serment bien
entendu mais on voulait posera s'il y
avait besoin après par contre vous nous
dites effectivement il y à des
changements qui vont s'opérer vous êtes
là depuis très peu de temps depuis que
la sortie du livre
ce directeur général vous êtes là aussi
depuis très peu de temps mais quid des
autres parce que quand on est sur la
route et en voiture si on fait un
dépassement de vitesse si les minimes on
a une petite sanction si les plus
importants on a une grosse sanction s il
est très important on a une suppression
du permis or il semblerait puisque vous
admettez qu'il ya beaucoup de
changements qui vont s'opérer et que les
directeurs les responsables précédents
ont commis quand même beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de fautes et on doit le
reconnaître quand même la gestion qui a
été faite au niveau de deux des
structures privées à but lucratif de la
vôtre de tête en particulier a été plus
à la recherche du profit car la
recherche du bien-être des résidents et
je le dis très clairement parce que je
pense que on doit on doit avoir cette
préoccupation permanente du bien-être
des résidants avant tout donc il faudra
quand même que vous nous disiez
que nous disiez par rapport au précédent
responsable de votre structure
qu'est ce qu'il en est qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire est ce que vous pensez des
poursuites sont engagées est ce que vous
pensez des engagés vous même est ce que
vous pensez qu'il est normal que le
gouvernement au dos t engages voilà il
faudra bien qu'on trouve une solution je
ne mens pas de réponse aujourd'hui c'est
un peu trop compliqué et puis vous avez
parlé des changements à venir je pense
que c'est important je pense que ce que
vous nous dites
capital effectivement l'autonomie des
établissements me paraît indispensable
de redonner un peu confiance à nos
résidents c'est indispensable et
peut-être et c'est là où on sera amené à
proposer des modifications en tout cas
au niveau des établissements à but
lucratif à la fois l'année dans des
transferts d'autorisation mais aussi
dans l'application un peu de ce qu'on
souhaite pour nono nos personnages et de
voir comment le système publics privés
associatifs ou privés à but lucratif
peut fonctionner correctement ensemble
sans qu'il y ait des dérives ou des
risques de dérives je crois que c'est le
plus important alors vous parlez aussi
la journée de mai je rappelle que notre
rapport va sortir fin juin donc il fera
le but c'est quand même de faire
beaucoup de préconisations des
propositions à la fois par rapport à vos
structures à but lucratif mais surtout
et beaucoup pour l'ensemble des
personnes âgées et sur la loi grand âge
dans j'espère en tout cas que ses
positions vont servir à quelque chose
j'espère vous avez prêté serment donc
j'espère que la sincérité de ce que vous
avez dit notamment des changements est
réel mais en tout cas je condamne et je
continuais beaucoup d'entre nous
condamne fermement tout ce qui s'est
passé auparavant
même si c'était pas généraliser mais
quand même on condamne fermement la
façon dont j'ai été géré certains
établissements la façon dont ça a été
fait la difficulté pour les résidents et
le résultat qu'on a aujourd'hui dans ce
niveau voilà ce que je voulais dire à la
fin et en deux mots moi je voulais vous
dire que votre communication très bien
préparée très bien léché pour redorer
l'image dans pea nous l'avons entendu
nous sommes en période électorale donc
nous prenons mais nous sommes très
attentive et et ce sont les actes et les
actions que vous allez mener qui vont
être déterminantes et comme bien sans
paraphraser bernard bonne le dire le
modèle des ehpad est aussi à questionner
et donc là dessus nous serons nous
aurons des propositions
le plaisir
alors je vous rappelle que nous
souhaitons bien bernard bonne a dit et
michel magne également la communication
de vos réponses écrites aux
questionnaires dans les meilleurs délais
vous nous avez proposé aussi de nous
transmettre les réponses aux
interrogations des corps d'inspection ça
c'est important pour moi aussi et puis
si vous pouvez nous communiquer à la
fois l'ordre de mission et les résultats
quand vous les aurez fournis par ces
cabinets de réputation internationale
qui font l'actualité mais sur un autre
sujet qui est sa plénitude elles sont
ces cabinets par l'état voilà pour cette
audition des dirigeants france d'orpea
en e p dg également le directeur général
du groupe qui était auditionné ce matin
depuis 9 heures vous avez pu suivre en
direct sur l'antenne de public sénat ses
dirigeants d'orpea france qui ont comme
cela dénoncèrent la plupart des
accusations du livre les fossoyeurs de
victoire car cette année il n'y aurait
pas de restriction de rationnement de la
nourriture pas non plus une volute de
vente et dans une chronique d'une
connivence entre les ars et le groupe
orpea également on a entendu ses
dirigeantes plaidé en faveur de
nouvelles mesures voilà pour donc ces
travaux de la commission merci d'avoir
suivi sur public sénat
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
continue sur publicsenat.fr
quand il était petit son prof de piano
lui avait dit qu'il ne serait sûrement
pas manuel pourtant c'est bien avec ses
mains qu'il accomplit aujourd'hui des
prouesses exceptionnelles des greffes
hors norme sa vie il la passe même à
reconstruire des corps descend des mains
l'homme augmenté l'homme hybride l'homme
éternel est ce que ce sera avec lui ou
sans lui le professeur laurent lantieri
est notre invité dans un monde un regard
les entretiens de public sénat
monde un regard avec laurent lantieri
vendredi à 19h sur public sénat
comme tous les cinq ans la france
choisit son président et comme tous les
cinq ans